in this video we'll talk about gas
gangrene this is a bacterial disease
which is caused by the bacteria
clostridium perfringens if this disease
is untreated then it might lead to
severe symptoms the injured tissue in
this disease produce foul smelling gas
that kind of justify the name gas
gangrene
let's look at the symptoms really
quickly so there could be skin
discoloration blackening of the skin
characteristic
black bubble lesion in the on the skin
there could be foul smelling discharge
from the lesions around the skin and
that is why the name gas gangrene other
than that there could be swelling
necrosis numbness on the affective site
fever etc
one important feature about clostridium
perfringens it can produce endospores
and endospores are really resistant to
extreme environmental conditions and
they can thrive in
any situation that means they are
resistant to starvation acidity
temperature or even desiccation and this
makes them pretty much untreatable
because they are resistant to many
antibiotics
now
this lesion is also known as
myonecrosis that means
a necrotic damage to the muscle tissue
and this is caused by the exotoxins
which are secreted by clostridium
perfringens the bacteria is an
opportunity pathogen that means whenever
ah there is a bridge in the skin barrier
the bacteria can enter the skin and
cause severe damages
and this was pretty much common in early
20th century where in the battleground
the surgeries are done in a non-sterile
situation that leads to invasion of
these bacteria in the wound and causing
gas gangrene
so the spores of clostridium perfringens
can germinate in the open wound and can
produce cytotoxic factors such as alpha
toxin and theta toxin alpha toxin has
hemolytic activity that means it can
rupture the rbc and theta toxin can
damage the blood vessels all these
things lead to a reduction in blood flow
to the infection site now this has
consequences because when blood flow is
reduced in the
infection site the immune cells are not
able to reach that infection site and
cannot combat the
pathogens that means the immune
effectiveness is reduced by damaging the
highways
so in an anaerobic environment the
clostridium perfringens can grow really
rapidly and ultimately it's an optimal
situation for its growth one important
factor that
discriminates these infections site from
the other infection is the type of
discharge
unlike other anaerobic infections where
the discharge is pass filled or purulent
in this case the discharge is
sweetly putrid that means
this discharge is uh
clear and it's thinner
because it
leads to a lot of death of
neutrophils
the toxins can be carried in the
circulation because already the
capillary walls are damaged it becomes
more permeable to everything toxins can
enter the bloodstream and can ultimately
travel to another
organ such as kidney and can cause
damages to that particular organ
ultimately this is involved in
shock renal failure or intravascular
hemolysis clostridium perfringens is
also a common cause of
acute food poisoning throughout the
world cdc estimates that one million
illness are reported every year in
united states altogether
let's talk about how we can
detect this particular bacteria in a
laboratory settings
so first of all
these bacterias are gram positive after
that they can be cultured on blood agar
plate and they would show a
characteristic double zone of beta
hemolysis
and that's pretty much determines their
presence
and you should also consult your doctor
immediately when you have this infection
or you think of having this infection
doctor might prescribe several
antibiotic cocktails that can help to
heal this infection but if there is
delay or ignorance that might lead to
severe situations such as a kind of
amputation there are
hyperbaric
treatments but there is a debate in the
effectiveness of this kind of treatment
anyway high dosage of penicillin and
doxycycline has to be administered for
this kind of diseases
anyway you can get all the notes and
flashcards for uh
these topics in my facebook page which
is provide the link is provided in the
description don't forget to like share
and subscribe you can support my channel
on patreon my courses are present in
unacademy which is india's online
learning platform using my code ap 10
you can get a 10 discount feel free to
connect
via social media i'll be happy to answer
your questions and happy to chat with
you guys see you in next video thank you